Oh
good socks good socks are very important
probably as important maybe more
important than good shoes a very
lightweight waterproof shell that you
can put on over whatever you've got
something that hopefully ways you know
less than 8 ounces and can be rolled up
and compressed and stowed in the corner
of a suitcase or a bag little
collapsible bags are great things to
have for your you know shopping for
groceries or whatever something that
compresses up like that and then unfolds
into this big bag those are things that
you just need to have all the time
wherever you go pair of pliers is a
really good thing technology-wise an
unlocked cell phone that's probably the
most important thing where do you have a
computer or not doesn't really matter
that's up to you I carry a computer
because I'm I'm working wish i could
leave it at home oh man to take a trip
without a computer and a power supply
and all the little doodads and wires oh
man happy have you so nice do people do
that to people travel without all that
stuff they must
they're there for anything that might
happen pair of pliers will help you pull
something out of a campfire you know I
like to bring those little little cans
of like Spanish like clams and white
beans or octopus and garlic sauce that
you can just pull open they're great to
bring on a camping trip because you just
open them up put it near the campfire
and starts to bubble and then you can
eat it you have warm octopus out in the
middle of the woods but you need a pair
of pliers to like pull it back out I
used a pair of pliers to help fix the
battery leads on someone's car in
Northern Cyprus one day out in the
middle of nowhere otherwise we would
have been stuck pliers are great liars
are there like fingers but they're made
of metal and they have more leverage and
you know they don't burn so easily
I don't go out of my way to look for
souvenirs I don't I don't need these
little physical reminders of where I
went on a trip I have good memories
usually but every once in a while I find
something that that you know calls out
to me as an unusual symbol of where i
was when i was in cambodia several years
ago I visited rubber plantation and just
wound up with a little seed for a rubber
tree in my possession and I I don't know
why I held on to it I didn't even really
remember holding on to it but it's just
kind of stayed with me and around me and
on my desk and among my things without
ever totally getting lost and I just
like it it's this it's this reminder
that these huge rubber plantations come
from these little seats and that
everything that we see that's made of
rubber these days is actually has its
origin in this strange little sort of
brown zebra striped seed that I have so
those are nice I look for I save
currency same currency just because
there's always some leftover I'm a big
bag of notes from countries i visited
and they're kind of interesting to go
through every once in a while really
looking forward to when my my daughter's
old enough to kind of understand the
idea of money and to be able to look at
these bills and say like this is Oh
who's that person on on that bill from
Hungary or who you know why is Gandhi
onil every single bill in India and not
not just some of them but I think he's
on like he's on all of them huh the
other thing I like to get whenever I can
is lithographs and etchings and various
prints at like flea markets and things
like that partly because well if they're
small they're sort of easier to
transport but also I like multiples I
like the idea that some little print I
get in Venice of three chickens
scratching on the ground is one of like
40 that were produced and somewhere out
there there's 39
people somewhere in the world who have
this little thing that I found you know
at a flea market in Venice and who knows
maybe all I'll wind up invited over to
someone's house somewhere in Slovakia or
Morocco or something like that no look
at the one else see I know those three
little chickens I have those three
little chickens too there's those are
sort of exciting moments when you when
you spot something like that